maestro Nicole tu es bien comme ça il y
en a mais je suis très bien comme
ça c'est
parti c'est parti allez c'est un truc de
[Applaudissements]
fou
là c'est le moment où on se libère on se
on se lâche tout le monde s'est dessiné
à sa façon on sait dessiner
intéressez-vous à ce qui se passe dans
le monde on reste pas qu'à la Réunion il
y a plein de belles choses à voir dans
le domaine artistique dans le domaine
[Musique]
contemporain cette pièce c'est aussi une
partie de du jouet avec nos expériences
depuis longtemps en fait les
mosambiquins vont en Afrique du Sud pour
pour travailler
et voilà aussi ce qu'on entend par
rapport à la migration par rapport à
tous ces
[Musique]
histoires et dans cet
album tout frais mon pays c'est la
consécration et la
synthétisation de
ans de vie pas mon pays la Réunion en
fait bien queère que fait honneur mais
c'est vraiment mon pays intérieur mon
fond de cœur
mon de l'eau de l'eau la terre la vie
IR
provid F
ou sinon ça com donneali le nom
combava j'aspire à peindre en fait
kiffer ma vie avec la
peinture redessiner un peu le paysage de
la Réunion c'est une manière aussi de de
remontrer de montrer la belle diversité
qu'on a en tant que fun FL et aussi de
de faire revenir la
nature au goû du
[Musique]
jour
c'est tout un système de distribution
d'air que va permettre de passer des
parf dans tout cet endroit là jusqu'à la
scène que les 40 et quelques m avec on a
bossé en amont et lui il m'a donné un
peu son monde qu'est-ce qu'il voyait
qu'est-ce qu'il sentait pourquoi cette
chanson était faite quelle couleur voilà
on a bossé un peu làdessusès vraie
création c'estuc peu fouou ce qu'on a
fait c'est le 7e c'est sa cou Saou
lumême même si N s le tempo doit ai le
même
TER l'album appelle anima cultura c'est
un mot que de mot ne comprend pas
justement m'apprend un mot que Deon
comprend pas parce que c'est d' langue
morte anim cultural ben un peu de
mystère derrière justement du fait que
Deon comprend pas mais anima il veut
dire l'âme déjà anima cultura il veut
dire premierre lecture comme
ça l'animal culturel l'âme et l'animal
culturel les Bones animaux culturels
quelque part al est quand même étonnant
un livre sans texte al excuse-moi ah
c'est je bouge trop je me décale je
disais non bouge pas c'est pas ouvert ah
oui bon ben on ser de recommencer alors
parce qu'il y a encore du maronnage en
fait en 1848 c'est étonnant et je pas
enregistré pour de
vrai
[Musique]
je suis désolé non ben écoute c'est pas
grave on sait qu'il nous arrive toujours
un truc en jour de tournage je suis
désolé c'est de ma faute j'aurais d mais
non mais je te fais trop confiance voil
non mais tu peux continuer à me faire
[Musique]
confiance
j'ai une maman un jour qui m'a écrit qui
m'a dit que sa fille elle était
totalement elle était pas bien limite
dépressive et qu'elle avait besoin
d'écouter une de mes chansons tous les
matins pour pouvoir se lever et tu te
dis
wou et tu te dis voilà tu sais pourquoi
tu te réveilles le matin tu sais
pourquoi tu fais toutes sacrifices parce
que ça vient aider aussi les gens à se
[Musique]
lever sera d'aller àot
Madagascar avec ce projet là mais avec
ce mélange de musique là pour que voilà
la réunion nous vivent ensemble comme ça
et nous la mélange de
[Musique]
différen
en fait nous l'a pris les bâtiments et
nous l'a fait en sorte de faire une
brigade donc l'écrit police nationale
ici mais élement pas icip plainte on a
un IML c'està dire un situt médico légal
où ça découpe les cadavres pour bien
regarder l'utopsie et tout ça et voilà
nous on a une super équipe d'co a
vraiment travaillé pour faire en sorte
que il ressemble à un commissariat
l'information que tout le monde a retenu
essentiellement c'est que le PAI d'une
baleine est tellement énorme que si la
bulle pourrait contenir un cheval donc
voilà entre autres ça ils ont bien
retenu a l'animal politique mais aussi
animal culturel et puis a beaucoup
d'autres références derè ça mais ça
c'est au fur à mesure nous
va n va dévoile ça je pense que c'est la
force la runion des fois nous dout mais
si nous prend l'âme notre pays et nous
mett dans notre cœur tient ça beau fort
pourout c'est un c'est un il travaille
contre la maladie contre ennuit et
cetera mais il faut travail faut travail
voilà tu ve réussir c'est travail tous
les jours pe çaz mais si on a l'ambition
un rêve faut aller au bout faut aller au
bout et merci d'être aussi notre Zor
chlo merci
merci
[Musique]
bonignant riti
pardon a bien
que voilà la réponse quelle question la
question al trop de chose à dire en
fait
[Musique]
le